[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABE SHERMAN: Thank
you, Gretchen,
for making time for us.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Well,
thank you so much.
I wish I could take
credit for the timing.
I mean, I guess in a more
subtle way, I can in a way
that coming forward
15 months ago
has started this floodgate
of other women feeling
the confidence and the
bravery and the courage
to do the same thing.
GABE SHERMAN: Yeah.
So I imagine--
maybe, maybe not--
we have some Fox News
viewers in the room
or watching on live stream.
But for those who didn't
watch Fox, and this is really
may be your first
time seeing Gretchen,
can you tell everyone
what motivated
you to write the book?
Obviously last year you were
in the middle of a crazy media
storm.
And now here you are, the
public face of this issue.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: So after I
jumped off the cliff by myself
on July 6, 2016,
where my story broke
and I filed a lawsuit
against my former boss
at the company where
I was working--
I mean, I had no idea what would
happen to me the next minute
or the next day.
So it was really an
out-of-body experience
as it started to unfold
and develop really quickly,
with the results
of my boss being
forced from the company and
other women coming forward.
I could have never,
ever predicted that.
And also, what started
happening at the same time
was that I started hearing
from thousands of women
all across the
country who started
sharing their own personal
stories of pain and shame
with me as well.
And I soon realized that
this was a pervasive epidemic
in our country, that it
wasn't just sexual harassment
in the television
industry or in Hollywood.
This was from all walks
of life, from single moms
who were working two jobs to
make ends meet as a waitress
to members of our military
to teachers to accountants.
I mean, it was every profession.
I grew up in the midwest where
my parents always encouraged me
to write back to people
and correspond and write
thank you notes.
So I started responding
to all these women.
And what I found out
was that they all
felt so grateful that I
was giving them a voice
because nobody had ever listened
to them or to their story.
And from that, I felt a sense
of duty to put together a book,
not only to honor
these voiceless women,
but also to give
practical advice
and move the ball
forward on this issue.
And look where we are today.
In a short period of
time, as you just said,
this is the national
dialogue right now.
GABE SHERMAN: Yeah.
So I know you can't discuss the
specifics of your time at Fox.
But can you take us a little
bit inside your state of mind
when you filed the lawsuit
against Roger Ailes, who
we should remember was the
most powerful man in media.
He had helped elect
three presidents,
was a kingmaker in
the Republican party,
and presided over a
ruthless media company that
was known for
attacking anyone inside
and outside the company
who questioned Fox.
And here you were, going to
file a lawsuit naming him
personally.
What was going
through your mind?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Well, courage
building is not something
that you do overnight.
I think it has a lot to
do with how you're raised.
Fortunately I had
parents who told me
I could be anything I wanted
to be every single day,
and that helped me to build
courage from a young age.
Still, when you decide to
do something like this,
it's a process.
And the final nail
in the coffin for me
was when I realized that
my job was coming to an end
after 25 years in the business.
And it was coming to an
end that wasn't my choice
to come to an end--
that I decided, if I
don't step up and speak up
about this issue and have
conviction on it, then
who else is going to do it?
And most important to me,
Gabe-- and you're a new father--
is I have a 12-year-old son
and a 14-year-old daughter.
And I don't want them to face
the same indignities that I've
gone through in my career.
And I was shocked that it
was still existing in 2017.
But I wanted to
eradicate it for them,
or at least do my
part to do that.
GABE SHERMAN: And I think
one of the things that
was unique to your situation is
that a lot of women, when they
come forward, are worried about
their stories being questioned
or shamed or doubted.
And I think what was
unique in your situation
is that your
colleagues, that there
was an orchestrated campaign
to discredit your story.
What did that feel like when
people that you worked with
were casting doubt
on your claims?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Well, you
find out who your friends are.
I mean, not only coworkers,
but you find out in life.
It was really fascinating.
You know, some
people who I hadn't
heard from in 30 years
reached out to me,
and that meant a lot to me.
Some people who lived
on my street never did.
So it was interesting
because as time went on,
people would approach
me and say, well,
I didn't want to bother you,
or I didn't know what to say.
You know, it's kind of
like when somebody dies,
people feel tongue tied.
And it would have been
just nice if they just
would have sent one
little line in an email,
like thinking of you or
whatever, because trust me,
when you do something
like this, you have
a lot of incredibly dark days.
And the only other thing I
would add to either the trolls
on social media-- or however you
want to describe those people
that you just brought up--
you can't waste too
much time worrying
about those who malign
you because really what
I wanted to do with this mission
was move the ball forward.
And it doesn't do any good
to sit around and worry
about people who said,
really bad things.
GABE SHERMAN: Just
this week we had
more revelations about
Harvey Weinstein,
other prominent
members in Hollywood,
and your former
colleague, Bill O'Reilly.
Sort of from the
30,000 foot view,
where are we in
this conversation
that your story, now
your book helped ignite?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: So I think
it's absolutely horrifying
that any company would protect
a harasser, a serial harasser,
for 30 plus years.
I mean, listen,
harassers don't continue
to be able to do
that in the workplace
unless they have help.
So enablers,
lawyers, assistants.
These were all people who
helped in the cover-up
and the shutting
up of the victims.
And we should all believe that
that is absolutely outrageous.
So from 30,000 feet,
what I'm saying now
is that women are
finally feeling
the courage and the bravery
to say, enough already.
We're not going to
take this anymore.
And looking at that MeToo
hashtag for me was just--
that was so empowering
just for me.
Even though the
stories were so awful,
it showed that every
woman, number one,
has a story, unfortunately,
but also that we're not
ashamed to speak up about it.
And we're shifting the shame
from the woman, where it never
should have been, to the
harasser where it belongs.
I've been fascinated by the
fact that we're still having
this national conversation.
GABE SHERMAN: Yeah.
And do you think--
we were just talking before
we sat down about Anita Hill.
And in a certain respect, sexual
harassment in the workplace
is not a new thing.
It's been something
our culture has been
grappling with for decades.
But sadly, here we
are in 2017, and we
realize that someone
like Harvey Weinstein,
who was exposed to be a
serial predator, quote,
people knew this was going on
for years and it didn't stop.
I mean, to me as a reporter
who covered Ailes's downfall,
am always shocked that this
behavior could have gone on
with such high profile people,
and no one said, wait a minute,
this isn't right.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: I know.
In fact, in
Weinstein's contract,
allegedly the board allowed
him to go on harassing.
They knew it was happening.
And they just said, well,
if another case comes up
you'll have to pay us a fine.
I mean, really?
The board of directors-- by the
way, none of them are women--
allowed that kind of pervasive
misogyny to continue.
That is absolutely
outrageous and horrifying.
GABE SHERMAN: That's where the
focus of my reporting-- a lot
of it has been on the
systems and the power that
allowed this behavior to go on.
And at Fox, a lot
of it was a system
that Ailes set up
to silence victims
through legal settlements, out
of court settlements, NDAs,
which we've talked about.
So to me, this is--
like with the Catholic
Church abuse scandal--
the focus should be on the
power, not the individuals.
It's the system that allowed
this abuse to take place.
Can you talk a little bit
about O'Reilly to the degree
that you can?
We learned, according
to "The New York Times"
that Fox News signed
him to a new contract
after knowing he made multiple
out-of-court settlements.
Does that indicate that the
company was taking seriously
protecting women, or were they
willing to look the other way
for ratings?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: So if
you read in the newspapers
after my story, there was
going to be a new beginning.
And I'll let you make
your own assumption
about that, since
they resigned him well
after my story had broken.
You know, what I
can say about that
is that for any company
to re-sign an individual
who had been dismissed for
sexual harassment allegations
and known settlements
already, and then
invite him to come back on
the air just last month,
that is absolutely horrifying.
And to think that there
was a cleanup on the way,
I don't think I'd
call that a cleanup.
GABE SHERMAN: And
the number itself.
I mean, a $32 million
private settlement.
O'Reilly has been out
there saying it's all BS
and it's not true.
And I think the number
speaks for itself.
Nobody spends that
amount of money
to settle a claim if there's
not some merit to it.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: That's exactly
what I tweeted the other night.
I just said, I don't care
how much money you have,
nobody pays $32 million
for false allegations.
And it was, I think, the most
re-tweeted Tweet that I've ever
sent in my entire life.
I didn't even intend for that.
It was just my general
reaction that--
and here's part of the problem.
And I know you know
this, Gabe, but I
want to make sure
we're clear about this.
When you sign a
settlement or you're
forced into arbitration, which
is also a secret chamber,
these are the two ways in
which our country has deemed
that we resolve these issues.
They're both in
silence for women.
What happens is that the
perpetrator can go out and say
whatever they want publicly.
And the women can't respond.
So is that fair?
That's just bias like you've
never even heard of before,
where the harasser can
go out and say whatever.
None of the
allegations are true.
And the woman can't speak
up because if she does,
then she'll lose the
settlement that she received
or she'll get in trouble
some other way legally.
So it's a flawed
system, and none of it
benefits the women at all.
GABE SHERMAN: We talked
a little bit about that.
We'll circle back to your story.
But you're touching on
kind of the public policy
aspect of this, which I find
really fascinating in the work
that you're doing.
To the degree that
there are laws in place,
how can we change the system so
that women in the workplace who
experience harassment
have a safe venue
to both air these claims
and get some sort of justice
or recourse?
GRETCHEN CARLSON:
So one of the things
I focus on in the book "Be
Fierce" is, should we really
have these claims and complaints
going to human resources?
And when I started
talking about this,
I did hear from a
lot of great people
who work in HR departments.
So I don't want to say negative
things about all of them,
because they said look,
we're trying to help.
And so I see that.
However, I think we need to
really be cognizant of the fact
that when the harasser could be
the top person of the country
who's signing the
paycheck, is really
the safest place to go to HR?
Isn't that a
conflict of interest?
I say that it is.
So in "Be Fierce", I advocate
a couple of new measures
that would maybe help more
women to come forward and keep
it a more independent process.
So one of them is to
hire an ombudsman, who
would be an independent, safe
person, maybe even anonymously,
that you would go to.
And you wouldn't feel
like you're walking down
your hallway looking over your
back knowing that you just
filed a complaint with somebody,
who many times the HR people go
right to the harasser
and tell them
that you filed a claim to make
your life even more miserable.
So that's one thing
that I proposed.
The second is, after
the Anita Hill case--
actually, that was
the first story
I covered as a
journalist, ironically,
and shortly thereafter,
I was harassed on the job
by a cameraman in a
rural part of Virginia
who talked to me
when we got back
in the car about
how I felt when he
touched my breasts by
putting the microphone on me.
And I actually envisioned
myself rolling out
of the passenger side door--
this was before cell
phones-- because I was so
panicked to get away from him.
So I've had other
experiences in my life
where I was sexually
harassed before my last place
of employment.
But basically, in a
nutshell, it drains you
of all the
self-confidence you've
built up in your entire life
to be known as a sex object
instead of for your brain
and for your talents.
So what I think happened
after Anita Hill is
that a lot of companies
decided to incorporate
sexual harassment training, have
that be part of their policy.
But what I found out in my
research is that a lot of times
it's just a cover your ass
facade for litigious reasons
and otherwise, for the
company to be able to say
we provide this.
So one of the things I
propose in "Be Fierce"
is we should really take the
focus of sexual harassment
training and move it to
more bystander training.
How do we encourage
other employees
who know that this is
happening, may witness it,
or have been told by a colleague
that it's happening to also
have the courage to come forward
and not feel that they will
also be retaliated against?
We should really
refocus the training
on how do we celebrate the
people who have the courage
to come forward and say
it's not a safe working
environment instead of
just focusing on hey,
here's some case studies
of sexual harassment,
and sign on the
dotted line so that we
know for sure you
came to this training
so that we're off the hook.
Let's really put effort
into getting the enablers
and bystanders to
become our allies.
GABE SHERMAN: And in many
cases, the harassers themselves
use the HR departments as a foil
to say that well, no one came
forward to make allegations.
How could these claims be
true because there's never
been a formal process?
But I think that speaks to
what Gretchen is talking about,
that a lot of people don't
feel that HR is a safe place
to make these claims.
So instead they bottle
them up, and then
the only recourse they
have is through litigation.
And that obviously
has its own problems.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Well,
because most of the time
you don't take a
sexual harassment
case to an open court.
Why?
Because prevalent now
in employee contracts
are these arbitration clauses.
GABE SHERMAN: So talk about
secret corporate courts,
as you call them, and the
way in which our employment
contracts-- and perhaps a lot of
people here at Google have them
as well--
when you work for a
big company and you
have a claim, that you
can't sue them in court.
You have to deal with it in a
secret, off the record court.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Right.
And so this was
never the intention
of an arbitration clause.
When the Supreme Court ruled
on this over 20 years ago,
it really was to
not clog the courts,
but not intended for
sexual harassment claims
or discrimination claims.
And then that's where they're
being utilized, though.
So what happens is that
you basically sign away
your Seventh Amendment right
to an open jury process when
you start your job.
And listen, nobody starts a
job and thinks to themselves,
wow, I expect to
get into a dispute.
I mean, I know I didn't.
But it's a dark day when
you find out in a dispute
that you can never tell
anyone what happened ever.
And that's what arbitration is.
So it's secret,
first and foremost.
So here's a hypothetical.
The woman is being sexually
harassed on the job.
She files a complaint.
They immediately put
her into arbitration.
The company's going, whew,
we don't have to tell anyone.
The woman loses her job.
In arbitration you don't
get the same amount
of witnesses or depositions.
The company usually picks
the arbitrator, and only 20%
of the time does the
employee actually win.
And there's no appeal.
Does that sound fair?
So what ends up happening is
the woman is out of the job.
She can never tell
anyone what happened
or that she went
through this process.
And the harasser, many
times, gets to stay,
and nobody knows about it.
And that's been going on for
the last couple of decades.
It's why even I didn't realize
how pervasive this issue is
in the workplace because we
don't hear about these cases.
But the reason we don't
hear about these cases
is because they're being
forced into secrecy.
GABE SHERMAN: And
when I was reporting
on the Fox News sexual
harassment scandal last summer,
one of the women I
interviewed, RudI Bakhtiar, who
was a correspondent at Fox News
years ago, she broke her NDA.
And she was very courageous.
She was the first woman to
come forward on the record
and give an interview to
me about her experience
of harassment after signing
an arbitration settlement.
And she told me the night
before her interview
that she needed to transfer
money, basically take
all of her life savings and move
it to a different bank account
because she was so terrified
that Roger Ailes or Fox
News would come after her
after her interview with me.
And she thankfully was brave
enough to share her story,
and that really helped catalyze
and bring the Fox News scandal
into the light.
But I think that speaks to
the fear that these NDAs have,
that they inspire in victims.
And I guess what I wanted to ask
you is, do you think companies
should, now that we're in the
middle of this conversation,
basically say if you've
experienced harassment,
we think this is an important
public issue to discuss
and we should release
you from NDAs.
That That would be very big
of companies to do that.
I think we should
all demand that.
Let me just say a
little bit about Rudy
because she was so
brave in doing that,
and she was an amazing reporter.
She was from Iran.
She was covering foreign
policy for us at Fox
and did a great job.
And suddenly she
wasn't there anymore.
And I always wondered,
what happened to Rudy?
10 years later,
when she came out
to defend me and
tell her own story,
I guess I found out
what happened to Rudy.
And I tell that
story because she's
the microcosm of the
macrocosm of all these women
who've had the American
dream taken away
from them for no reason except
because of some random jerk.
And that's why we should
all be concerned about this.
As far as NDAs, there's
now a national call
for the Weinstein Company
and for other companies
to release women from them.
I urge all of you
to join that mission
because I'm not asking
for businesses to not
have NDAs for business secrets.
We all understand that.
I feel comfortable signing
an NDA that I'm not
going to talk about
some new technology
that you're developing
or some big news
story that we were only privy
to at our place of employment.
That makes sense.
But not about issues that
are violating a human being.
So I think that we should all
have a national call for NDAs
to not exist anymore.
Let's see if
companies will do it.
GABE SHERMAN: Yeah.
But I agree.
I think companies have
twisted the use of NDAs
to cover up violations
of human rights
rather than protecting corporate
secrets or trade practices.
So I think that clearly is
something that hopefully
would galvanize support.
I want to circle
back to your story,
because I've had the
privilege of learning more
about you and your life.
And for all of you
out there, Gretchen
is a remarkably
impressive woman.
She was trained as
a concert violinist.
She was, obviously
famously, Miss America.
And she went to
Stanford University.
She is somebody who has
set her goals on things
and achieved them.
And I want to talk about how
you approached your lawsuit
and making sure that your claims
would be serious and taken
seriously, and advice you
have for other women who
are possibly thinking about
coming forward, what steps they
can take to make sure
that they're protected
and be disciplined
in how they do it.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Well, thank
you for bringing that up.
By the way, we should mention
that I was always forbidden
from ever knowing Gabe.
I was never supposed
to ever meet Gabe, know
who Gabe was
because he was doing
a lot of investigative work.
And I do think it's ironic
that we have become friends.
Whoever thought I'd be sitting
on stage with Gabe Sherman?
So that in and of itself, thank
you, Gabe, for all the work
that you have done.
In Chapter Four of
my book "Be Fierce",
I wanted to make
sure that I laid out
a playbook for women, and
for men, who go through this.
So it's my 12-point plan.
I don't think it's
ever been done before,
and what I'm
encouraging women to do
is just take it
right out of the book
and put it in the back
pocket, because oftentimes
what happens to women
in these situations
is we think we can beat
this if we just work harder.
We think the
harassment will stop.
They'll finally really
appreciate us for our brains.
And so we keep
persevering and we
keep persevering and
putting up with it.
And one day we
finally just combust,
and we might go
file a complaint.
And you know what the
problem with that is?
We don't have a plan.
So my playbook is a plan.
You can't put the genie
back in the bottle
once you go and
make that complaint.
I'll tell you my
top three things
in the plan of 12 points.
Number one, you have
to call a lawyer first.
There are resources
in the back of my book
that can show you exactly
where you can call somebody.
They'll take the
call for 10 minutes.
Tell them what
your situation is.
They'll let you know
the laws in your state,
because they're
different, and what
your statute of
limitations are, and also
other really important things,
like can you have evidence?
Can you record?
In 11 states it's illegal
to one party consent record.
So you need to know what
the laws are in your state.
Number two, document.
Document, document, document.
I talked to a bunch of women in
my book who had done just that.
They wrote a journal about
what was happening to them.
They saved e-mails.
They saved texts so
that they had evidence.
And then they were
fired and they
couldn't go back to their office
where they kept all that stuff.
So take it home.
Number three.
I know it's so hard, but tell
at least two trusted colleagues
because you're going
to need the witnesses.
We still live in a he
said, she said culture.
Even though we've seen a lot of
change over the last 15 months
that I'm so
appreciative of, you're
still not going to be believed.
And you're probably
going to be called
a liar and a troublemaker, and
you just can't take a joke.
So tell two trusted colleagues.
And I would recommend
telling a man
because, I hate to say it,
that's going to probably carry
more weight if, in fact, the man
says, I saw it or I heard it,
or she told me on December 5,
2017 that this happened to her.
At least then you have
people defending you
instead of feeling
like you're 100% alone.
Anyway, there are
nine other tips
that are in Chapter Four of
my playbook, "Be Fierce".
I think it's essential
that women and men get this
into their hands,
and that you pass
along this same gift of
courage to other people
that you know that may be facing
any injustice in their life.
This is not just about
sexual harassment.
This is about being fierce and
standing up and speaking up
about any way in
which you don't feel
you're being treated fairly,
whether that's pay in equity
or bullying in
school for our kids,
or not getting a seat
in the boardroom,
or not getting the
promotion you deserve.
This is about a movement of
standing up and speaking up
for you to be the best
person you can be.
GABE SHERMAN: We've
seen, obviously,
the swiftness of the downfall
of, say, a Harvey Weinstein.
Do you think now we're at
a place where companies
do have a zero tolerance policy
when a powerful executive has
been exposed for his behavior?
Or do you think,
unfortunately, this
may be kind of a
fleeting moment,
and we'll revert
to the status quo?
GRETCHEN CARLSON:
I am surprised,
based on how our news
cycles change so quickly now
and our attention
spans are so limited,
that we are still talking
about this three weeks
after the Weinstein story broke.
But I am so heartened
that we are,
because it means that all of
the work that I've been doing
and others have been doing
for the last 15 months
is paying off.
You know, when you think
about cultural shifts
with race relations or gay and
lesbian and transgender issues,
they don't happen overnight.
So the idea that we have come
this far in 15 months, Gabe,
I really feel--
I tend to be an
optimistic person,
but I really think
that this is amazing.
And I don't think we're
going to turn back.
Look at what happened now.
You have the Amazon
Studios executives.
You have the other
Hollywood director
with all those complaints.
GABE SHERMAN: 200 women.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: 200 women.
GABE SHERMAN: I was blown
away when I saw that LA Times
headline where
the director James
Toback had been accused
originally in an article
by 30 women.
And then several days
later, the newspaper
had heard from
more than 100 more,
and I think the
total was over 200.
Two things I felt as a
reporter, that it was shocking
that this was out there
and he wasn't in jail.
I mean, the guy seems like a
straight up sexual predator.
And then secondly,
that now women
have the courage to just
come forward and call it out.
I think men will not
be able to sort of do
that pervasive behavior without
the fear of exposure now.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Well, and
ones who have already done it,
they're in the fetal
position right now.
They're just waiting
for the women
to be emboldened at their
place of employment.
So I do see this as
a cascading effect.
What my hope is is that
media will continue
to cover this and cover the
stories of the women that
are not famous because that's
the majority of the women.
A young woman in
Boise, Idaho, you know?
GABE SHERMAN: Talk a
little bit about some
of the women you've
heard from who, again,
are everyday Americans
working either in the service
industry, in the
restaurant industry,
and what their
experience has been like
and how they've tried
to seek justice.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: So
basically, all of their stories
were nobody would
ever listen to me.
I never had a voice.
I was maligned.
I mean, it's the
same sort of story.
And I would just
wait for it as I
would respond to
all of these women,
and then eventually get on the
phone with them for the book.
Without failure, all
of them would say,
my industry is an old boys club.
It didn't matter what it was.
Even female-oriented
business areas
like retail or the
cosmetic industry.
And I think the one thing that
they felt so fearful of was,
can I really come forward,
because I need my paycheck.
And one of the questions that
really gnawed at me, Gabe,
and gave me a lot
of sleepless nights
was how do I help the single
mom who can't afford to do this,
doesn't have the
resources that I had,
doesn't have the national
platform that I had.
And so through my fund that
I've set up, Gift of Courage,
I've now started the Gretchen
Carlson Leadership Initiative,
which will kick off next month,
November, in Dallas Fort Worth.
It's a nine-city
tour, three days
of workshops in each city
for underserved women
where they can come
for free and learn
about sexual harassment,
domestic violence,
get legal advice,
and learn how to have
a voice civically
and politically
in life, because what tends
to happen when you are going
through something like this
in your life, you feel alone
and you feel like you
don't have a voice,
not just on that issue.
You feel like you don't
have a voice on anything.
And I want to be able to provide
these women the opportunity
to become involved
in their communities
and get out of the shadows
of becoming a victim.
So I'm incredibly proud to
be financing that leadership
initiative as the
start to helping
more women to have a voice.
GABE SHERMAN: And you know,
obviously we can't have
this conversation in a vacuum.
And I think we have to look
at the national political
landscape that
we're all living in.
And we have a president
in the United States
who himself has been accused
by multiple women of very
similar types of
unwanted advances
and himself was caught on tape,
the famous "Access Hollywood"
tape, boasting about
what he does with women.
Are you surprised or--
I guess what I'm
trying to get at is,
do you think you know
the election in November
was sort of the last gasp
of that old culture where
that behavior was tolerated?
Or do you think
somehow politics is
different than
corporate America,
where people are willing to look
the other way because they care
about x, y, or z
issue, and they just
want to vote for their party?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Well, I
think that until recently it
was similar in
the sense that you
had a lot of people
covering up, and also
that people put
political policies ahead
of human decency.
For me, listening to that tape,
sorry, it was really personal.
GABE SHERMAN: Well,
you know Donald Trump.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: I
know Donald Trump.
I've known him for 27 years.
And a week after my story
broke, he came out against me
and said that from
everything he had read,
that he didn't believe me.
So it was personal for me when
I heard the "Access Hollywood"
tape.
And I feature, actually, Natasha
Stoynoff, the "People" magazine
writer who accused him
of unwanted advances,
in my book "Be Fierce".
I felt it was important
to give her a voice.
You know, that "Access
Hollywood" tape,
if you're a parent, I hope you
used it as a teachable moment
for your kids.
I know I did for mine.
And again, forget
political policy.
It's my opinion that the way
in which we treat human beings
supersedes that.
And that's all I cared
about with that tape.
I wanted my kids to know, this
is not how you treat people.
Now here's the difference.
When powerful people in
private companies are exposed,
they can be fired.
But we can't fire politicians
who've been elected.
That's just up
for the next vote.
So I guess, in a way, you can.
But it's not something that
would happen as swiftly.
So I guess we'll just
have to wait and see
how this all flushes out and
what reaction that will have
amongst the American people.
Everyone still has a vote.
GABE SHERMAN: So I would love
to open it up to the audience.
If anyone has questions,
you can please step to,
I think there's two microphones,
and just say your name,
and you're free to ask
questions if you have them.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: There's
our first brave soul.
AUDIENCE: Gretchen, thank you
so much for being here today.
Your words are
incredibly inspiring.
And I'm so appreciative
you've taken a stand
to represent women who
really do need this voice.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One question I
had for you in Chapter Four
was the idea of
training in civility.
Can you give us some examples
of companies that have done this
and have been successful
with that effort?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: So there is an
international cosmetic company
which has really gone way
beyond in being progressive
about this bystander training.
And that's really what
I mean about civility.
It's about let's teach
employees what to do
instead of what not to do.
That is the essence of it.
And the interesting thing that
I learned from this company
was that they're 70% female
employed around the world.
And even though they have these
incredibly progressive ways
to report it--
and once a week this
committee gets together
and listens to all
the complaints,
and they handle
them immediately.
But here's what they told me.
They don't really have a lot of
sexual harassment complaints.
And I was like, wow,
how simple is that?
I said, why?
They said, well, 70% of
our company is women.
So that led me to really
start thinking about, wow,
wouldn't it be
fabulous if we just
started employing more women, as
we should be, into these roles
and put them into
positions of power
so that this type of
activity doesn't happen.
You see, this is
how it prospers is
that we don't have enough
women in those positions
being able to say stop.
But it's why I'm calling on men
especially to help us with that
because as long as men dominate
running the Fortune 500
companies right now--
what is it, 94%--
we need them.
And we want them.
And by the way, in "Be Fierce",
I have an entire chapter on men
because I found so
many great men already
out there doing fantastic work.
It's my longest chapter.
So most men want to help us.
Most men want a safe work
environment for women.
We just have to convince them
to take that little extra step
of courage and stop
being the bystander
and stop being the enabler,
and help us in being an ally.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My name is Kelsey.
I just wanted to thank you so
much for being here and sharing
your story, and telling us
how to be fierce, I guess.
And you spoke a lot about
harassment in the workplace.
Obviously that what your book
is about and that's your story
is, and speaking with the
women about the industries
being a boys club.
In my experience, I feel like
our society is a boys club.
And I was wondering
if you have any advice
or for women that are harassed
in public on the street.
I know every day I face that.
And it's really hard to
be catcalled and harrassed
just going home or coming to
work, or anywhere that I go.
And I feel like I'm
losing my power.
And I know that your book is all
about taking your power back.
So I feel safe at work,
obviously-- thanks, Google--
but what advice do you have for
women to take their power back
in public or in the street?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Right.
And that happens because they
feel like they can, right?
To me it's the
insecurity of that person
calling out and trying to
take away your confidence.
So it's one of the things
that I say in the playbook
that you can also do in the
workplace, is to take offense.
Not that I'm not a funny person.
Listen, I like to have more fun
than anyone that I really know.
It's not that I
can't take a joke.
It's that you need to take back
your self-esteem and your pride
and just say, oh,
thank you so much.
I don't really
appreciate that, though.
You can say it in a
non-threatening way.
But the other
really central thing
that I think changes society
is the way in which we
choose to raise our children.
And at the end of the book,
I have a whole chapter
on parenting.
And really what I
think is crucial
is how we raise our sons.
I think it's imperative that
we teach gender equality
within the family
unit, whether that's
a husband or wife together, or
partners, or single parents,
or whatever the case
is, they're watching us
and they're hearing us.
And if you're showing
respect for gender at home,
that's what they're going
to carry through when
they get to the workplace.
So I think it's really central.
I think we should be
doing sexual harassment
training and classes
for middle school kids,
and moving on up
into high school.
I'm doing a college campus
tour with my book "Be Fierce"
because especially on college
campuses, one in five women
are going to faced
sexual assault.
And what does the
Greek system do?
What kind of messages-- not
to narc on them completely,
but what does that teach our
young men about how to be?
And then they go right from
there to the workforce.
So I really think that
getting to our young people
is essential and crucial to
moving the needle forward
for ultimate respect for women
once we get into the workplace
and on the streets.
Thank you, Kelsey.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much for coming
today and for so bravely
sharing your story, because this
is a system that perpetuates
in secrecy and shame.
And I don't know how much
you can answer this question,
and I don't mean it to
sounds politically pointed.
But having spent time
in a media environment,
which arguably has actively
perpetuated objectification
of women and a very
rape-supportive culture with
the active endorsement and
promotion of our now president,
who's advocated sexual
violence against women--
how do you reflect on your
time and participation
in that system and your
experience of then being
so publicly rejected from it?
GRETCHEN CARLSON:
Well, what I can say
is that, to a certain
extent, all people
can fall into cultish behavior.
I've always been a
supporter of women, always.
Call my mom up.
She used to get so bugged by me
calling her early in my career
and throughout and saying, women
aren't paid fairly, et cetera.
And she'd be like,
why do you always
have to talk about
women's rights stuff?
And I'm like, 'cause
I'm living it.
And then when she started
running a company later
in her life, in her 60s,
and still today at 76,
she calls me every
day and says, now
I know you're talking about.
That's the extent of what I
can say about my last 11 years.
But please know
that I have always
been an advocate for women.
GABE SHERMAN: Well, and you
mentioned just on that point,
on Twitter, I think,
recently I saw you said,
you don't know what
my parameters were.
So I guess that was
alluding to how,
even within the system
at Fox, you were trying
to carve out your own space.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Thank you.
You can say that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Your words are very inspiring,
and we're in a moment
right now where more women
are feeling the courage
to come forward.
I was struck by your
comment around finally
the day when you're recognized
for your brains, not
your beauty.
And I am sure many women
in the room, and men,
can relate to that,
of being complimented
on your looks instead
of your talents.
I had a colleague toast a
big project, and in front
of 40 people, comment
on how good I looked
as well as being
talented on the project.
And at that moment,
I realized, wow,
no one would ever say
that to a male colleague.
You wouldn't say he's
so great at his job,
and he looks so great.
You would never hear that.
So how do you think we
can more proactively model
emphasizing talents over
looks in the worth of women
in the workplace?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: I mean,
again, it starts young.
Your story reminds me of
Senator Kirsten Gillibrand
from this state, actually.
I interviewed her for the book.
And she was telling
a story about how
when she was at her law firm
before she ran for office,
that similarly, she
had won this huge case.
And at the toast, they talked
about her great new haircut.
She was like, wait a minute.
I just had this huge win.
And it was so demoralizing,
and your self-worth just
drains in quick fashion.
I don't know, there's
something in our society
that doesn't allow
us yet to honor
a woman who happens to
be attractive, smart,
and talented.
There must be something
wrong with her, you know?
So we focus, then,
on the looks first.
Now I'm going to be
the first to tell you
that I think media
plays into that.
I don't really
watch TV that much.
I just really have
been a news junkie.
And over the last
couple of months,
when I turn on
prime time TV, I'm
horrified that my kids might
be watching this stuff,
and the sexualization of women.
So I think that's
where it comes from.
And as parents, I don't know
how we completely control that.
You can control it in your house
as much as you possibly can,
but they go to school and they
do live in the outside world.
And are we really going to
be able to change the imagery
that we're putting out to our
kids, not to mention porn?
So to me, the way to
really try to combat that
is to raise our
sons differently.
I come back to that point.
GABE SHERMAN: And
I just want to jump
in on that, because I
notice in a lot of the news
accounts of the Weinstein
and these other scandals,
people would come
forward and say, oh,
for my daughter I'm
going to do this.
And as a father
of a new daughter,
I know the intention is there.
But to me, I also find that
language diminishing of women,
because it shouldn't
just be for daughters.
They're equal to men.
It should be a human issue.
And whether you have
a son or a daughter,
I want to raise my
children to be respectful.
And I'm not speaking out, or
I don't report on this issue
because I have a daughter.
GRETCHEN CARLSON: Right.
I mean, I will give
cred to the men who
stop me on the streets of
New York and shake my hand
and do say thank you
for my daughters.
I think it hits home
for fathers more
when they hear these stories and
they do have daughters at home.
And if that ignites them
to be part of this "Be
Fierce" movement, fantastic.
But you're exactly right.
I have often said I
worked more for my son
than I did for my daughter.
And what I meant
by that was that I
wanted him to see
what I did every day
and respect his eventual
female colleagues
in the workplace in the same way
in which he looked at his mom.
So I do agree that the
parity is essential.
And actually, more of the
focus should be on the sons
than the daughters.
AUDIENCE: So actually, as
a mother to a daughter,
my question was about just the
conversation with a daughter.
She's eight years old.
And I think one of the
most difficult times for me
as a parent was
election night, just
knowing that in the
morning I would have
to break this news of
this horrible bully
that she'd come to
kind of understand
was now elected popularly,
or not popularly, whatever.
GABE SHERMAN: Electoral college.
AUDIENCE: As the
leader of this country.
GRETCHEN CARLSON:
Electoral college, right?
GABE SHERMAN: Constitutionally
he was elected.
AUDIENCE: So I had to
explain all this to her.
I've never felt so
much fear and just
devastation in trying to
explain a happening to her.
And I was just
trying really hard
not to break down in front
of her, and to tell her,
this is going to be OK.
But anyway, so just
listening to this,
and having had my
own experiences,
and watching all of
this come forward,
I wonder about how to
talk to her about what
may end up, unfortunately, being
her experiences in the future.
And I just wanted to get your
thoughts on what would you
say to a daughter?
I don't actually know if
you have a daughter or not.
But what can we do
to protect our girls
and help them to
protect themselves?
GRETCHEN CARLSON: So I have
a 14-year-old daughter,
who actually I just took with
me on my LA part of my book tour
because I thought it was really
important for her to see me
out-- well, she also
thought LA was cool--
but to even take
her out of school
to show her what mom was doing.
And I think it's imperative
that our kids see
us standing up and speaking
up and being courageous,
because I can tell you what,
it transferred to my kids
almost immediately.
My greatest concern was how
will my kids fare through this?
And I've seen the bravery
in my kids transplanted.
It's contagious.
So my daughter finally
had the courage
to speak up at school about
some kids who were bugging her,
and came home and said, mom, I
did it because I saw you do it.
That is how it starts.
And as far as being however
you felt about the election,
I really want to turn it around
and say that it's a positive.
This is our chance to be able
to have a voice on these issues
and speak about
them more openly.
I have to look at
it optimistically,
and currently, where
we are right now,
I do think it's optimistic
that we're talking
about these issues so much.
And third, I would just say
that eight years old may
be a little young, but I played
the "Access Hollywood" tape
for my kids on purpose
because I wanted them to hear
how you don't treat people.
And I think that's the way
in which we move forward
on this issue is to be
open and honest about it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Steph Hoffman.
Thank you for being here.
So my question for you is I
feel a greater sense of urgency
than just the role
modeling for our children.
I couldn't agree with you more.
I have a four-year-old daughter
and an eight-year-old son,
and I believe so strongly
in the best thing I can do
is role model the behavior
I want to see in them.
But to the point of
urgency, because it's
going to be a long
time until they're
in middle school and high
school and in the workforce,
you talked about parameters.
And I'm sure you can't
share specifically.
Maybe you can talk
about it hypothetically
or in the abstract.
What guidance would you have?
I feel very privileged
working at Google.
I'm not saying we're perfect,
but I feel very privileged.
So I'm curious to hear
from you perspective
on parameters or grassroots
things that we could do.
I'm just horrified by what
you're describing in contracts
that people sign and
awareness that you
hope to bring through
this movement, what
I would call a movement.
What can we do from a
grassroots standpoint
to help catalyze change?
GRETCHEN CARLSON:
One of the things,
especially at progressive
companies like Google,
I think it it's really
important to put together
group discussions of employees
and talk about whether or not
you have arbitration
clauses, and whether or not
you can work with
HR to possibly,
let's talk about amending these,
or at least taking the secrecy
out of arbitration, or at
least giving your employees
the choice of
whether or not they
want it to be secret or not.
Start group discussions about
that in progressive companies
that are willing to really
listen to their employees.
I think that that is one
way to start, and to also
look at your sexual
harassment training policies.
I know that what
happened to me over time
was that they
eventually just came
through compliance on your
computer, and you just had to--
instead of actually
going to the training,
we just had to check off boxes.
And everyone pretty much just
did it as fast as they could.
But really lobby
within your company
for changing the way in which
you are training people,
specifically, to what
we were talking before,
about bystander training.
Don't just teach us about
what sexual harassment is
and give us case studies and
say here's what bad people do.
Teach us about how do we
empower people to come forward
and help.
That's really the
essential training.
So those two things
I would encourage
you to have, just like you
might have a book club,
but to come together.
I've already heard
from young people
all across the country, since
I've been on tour, that they're
starting these
kinds of movements
within their own companies.
And also I would have,
thirdly, the discussion
about the
confidentiality clauses.
Yes, let's protect business
secrets, especially
at a place like Google.
I know you're on
the cutting edge
and nobody wants
to violate that.
But do we really have to
be secret about everything?
Let's give a voice
back to our employees
because that is so
incredibly empowering.
And that only makes the
employee want to work here more
and stay here for a long time
if they know that they're
in a safe environment.
Thank you.
GABE SHERMAN: I think this is
all the time we have today.
Thank you so much for
participating in this very
important discussion.
And let's all give round
of applause for Gretchen.
[APPLAUSE]
as